[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome, welcome.
FELICIA DAY: Hello.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Have a seat.
Yeah, I've got
your book up here.
FELICIA DAY: You've
got Post-it notes.
MALE SPEAKER: Mine came
with fancy Post-it notes.
FELICIA DAY: Are you
getting graded later?
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe.
I don't know.
FELICIA DAY: Let's
grade him later.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Gosh.
So your resume has been
all over the place.
And I don't think
I've actually talked
to anybody who's had as much
internet-specific stardom.
People have become stars
and then gotten famous
on the internet.
And you kind of flipped
the bit on that,
which has been very cool.
FELICIA DAY: I guess so.
I have a weird
pathway that I don't
know if other people could
duplicate but at the same time,
I wrote the book
because I thought
there were some universal
things in my book
that I thought people
could take away.
And hopefully, just embrace
who they are a little bit more.
That's kind of the
theme of my book
because I got where I
am and did the things I
did because I just
kind of followed
the weird paths life took me.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, yeah.
I guess for those
who don't know,
I didn't actually
introduce the book--
"You're Never Weird on the
Internet (Almost): A Memoir"
by Felicia Day.
Right here.
With a foreword by Joss
Whedon, which is awesome.
So did your friendship
with Joss and Will Wheaton,
and all these other guys,
and Neil Patrick Harris,
and all the people
you worked with--
FELICIA DAY: Wow, that's a
lot of names you dropped.
MALE SPEAKER: I know.
You can pick it up.
I gotta bump you up a
little bit here, right?
FELICIA DAY: Thank
you, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: So, how did
these friendships come to be?
Because you started
filming The Guild
in like, your tiny little garage
on, like, no money, right?
FELICIA DAY: Yeah, well, I
guess the fancy people I know,
I've collected over the
years through different ways.
Joss Whedon-- I
was recently hired
for a role on Buffy the
Vampire Slayer, last season.
They hired a bunch of
like red-shirt girls,
who basically were killed
off during the season.
So you'd always, like, get the
script on your doorstep and go,
am I dead?
Am I dead?
Oh no, she died.
But I'm not dead.
Yay!
I survived.
Actually, in the lore, I'm the
head of the New York Slayers.
So just-- I'm not dead.
Just to be clear.
Any trivia.
I am an actual slayer.
And one day, this dude
sat down at the table
with a bunch of
the red-shirt girls
and was asking us questions.
I was like, OK, he's seems cool.
And then he says
something about,
well, you know, actors usually
don't get college degrees.
And I was, like,
excuse me, but I
was the valedictorian of my
class and I have a math degree.
And I studied music.
And he said, OK.
And everybody was just
like, what did she just do?
And I was like, well,
I schooled that guy.
And afterwards, I learned
he created the show.
He was just that guy.
So I was convinced, next time
I got a script on my doorstep,
I would be like, oh dead.
And killed by a library
book on her head
because she's a know-it-all.
But in fact, he did not do that.
Because I was, kind
of, an oddball,
he embraced, I guess, the
fact that I was an oddball.
And I got to be a
part of his, sort of,
Whedonverse, which
is very-- it's
kind of a tight-knit
group of people who
socially support each other.
I mean, he has this
spirit of family
that I am blessed
to be a part of.
So I've worked with him over
the years in "Buffy," and I
was in "Dollhouse"
and "Doctor Horrible,"
which was a great project.
It was a web series
that he did because he
was frustrated with his
opportunities in Hollywood.
That's why I created The Guild.
So there's sort of a link there.
And then everybody else, Will
Wheaton I just knew socially.
And I was like, I want to
create this guy for The Guild
who's a dick in a kilt.
Because I love kilt guys.
So you, kilt gamers?
I'm like, they're kind of hot
but they're like, aloof and--
[LAUGHTER]
It was before
beards were popular
and they're, like,
hairy everywhere.
So I wanted to
create this character
and I kind of knew him
through somebody else.
And I pitched him.
And I took him out to a
coffee place that had $8 cups
of coffee.
And it was like,
I'm a high roller.
That was high rolling for
web series, of $8 coffee.
MALE SPEAKER: So, basically,
the moral of the story
is you like hairy guys
in kilts and that's
how it all came to be.
FELICIA DAY: I'm attracted
to them artistically.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So you obviously
have a good track record
of being able to write
things and have then become
successful.
So why the book?
Why were you, like,
oh, yay, I'm going
to do more things in my life
and write this wonderful book?
FELICIA DAY: You mean, I
should talk about myself,
and then record an
audio book where
I talk to myself about myself?
That was, yes, it was a
weird thing to sign up for.
Well, I guess, the
point was, after I
created Geek and Sundry,
which was funded and created
by YouTube-- helped me start
my business, which is awesome.
Thank you Youtube.
[APPLAUSE]
I was asked to go around the
country presenting my story
to a lot of people,
either through advertiser
meetings or universities
or speeches like this,
at corporations.
And of course I was like, I've
never done a speech before.
So I kind of put together this
sort of janky PowerPoint slide
thing.
A lot of the pictures are
in this book right now
telling my journey from
weird homeschooled girl
to business owner.
And since people responded
to it-- and at conventions
I go to over the years,
people would say,
hey, you inspired me to
say I'm a gamer at work,
even though I didn't
ever tell anybody before.
Or, I decided to write a
web series because of you.
Or, you know, a
lot of creativity.
I said, hey, this could be
useful for people on a bigger
scale than just going
to speeches like this.
So that's why I
kind of dived in.
And also, it's just
a creative exercise.
I've always wanted
to be an author
and it seemed like
the right time
to sort of encapsulate my
story of finding success
through increasing
your individuality.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
FELICIA DAY: You seem skeptical.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, no.
That was a much more complicated
answer than I expected.
FELICIA DAY: OK, I talk a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, that actually
leads to my next question.
The writing style is very, very,
like, stream of consciousness.
You're just like, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, fuck.
Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, fuck.
FELICIA DAY: Don't say
that because I tell
people it's great for children.
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, children have
to learn how to speak
like that eventually.
FELICIA DAY: It's true.
Treat them like adults.
But no, I mean, I
appreciate that.
I spent a year on the draft.
So it wasn't as if I was
just, like, here's a book.
Buy it.
I spent a long time breaking
it down and thinking
about each piece
as far as, like,
is this useful to someone?
Is this section, is the story,
something that someone else
could take something away from?
Or is it just me looking
clever or hilarious?
I cut all that out
because at the core of it,
I want this to be a useful book.
I want it to inspire people to
really pursue the things that
make them an individual.
Because that's where I think
you find success and meaning
in this world.
As well as just trying to be
creative and out of the box
without result-oriented
behavior.
Because really, if I had
just jumped in and written
something for myself, I
wouldn't be here today.
It wasn't for external goals.
It was for just really wanting
to tell a story that was mine.
And, yeah, so that's
why I decided to do.
And hopefully, people
take that away.
Or, just, you know,
read it for Joss Whedon.
That's fine too.
MALE SPEAKER: At one
point, you mentioned
that when you moved out
to Hollywood, eventually,
like after college, and
whatnot, you originally
were doing things for like the
Hollywood people, and whatnot.
And then, at one point,
you're like, all of a sudden
when the comments started coming
in on episode one of The Guild.
You're, like, holy
crap, this is amazing.
I want to do things
for internet land, now.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
No, I went to college
when I was just barely 16.
So clearly, I had a
great dating life.
I mean, it was illegal.
I didn't date.
So.
[LAUGHTER]
And my mom drove me
to college every day.
So clearly, I can't write the
next "Revenge of the Nerds"
because I don't know actually
how people partied at college.
But I came from this world where
achievement was very based on
how hard you worked.
It was mathematical
and I studied math.
It was a mathematical equation.
The harder you worked,
the more you achieved.
And then I moved to Hollywood
where I was like, hey,
I'm enrolled in every class.
I have all the head shots.
Discover me.
And that didn't
work because it's
a very external-based world.
And kind of growing
up in a vacuum
like I did as a
homeschool person,
I wasn't used to being judged
on my appearance for the things
that people wanted from me.
And a lot of things
that I loved,
like math and science
fiction, and geeky things
like video games.
I think if I were in
school, I would've
been dissuaded from pursuing
those or being proud
about saying that I loved
those things because of the way
I was born.
I'm a girl, you
kow, the way I look
would influence what
people expected of me.
And I found that
pressure to be enormous.
I found it to be infuriating
and demoralizing.
And, ultimately, the
message in my book
is that you have to change that.
Like, you can't influence
the choices of your life
because of the cliches
of the way you were born.
And that is something that we
need to all strive together
to break.
Because if we're limited by
other people's needs for us,
then we're selling ourselves
short in every way.
And that's something that I
eventually push back against,
not like in a very
methodical way early on,
but by just looking
for an outlet
to be in control somehow.
And that's why I
picked up a camera
and started shooting in
my garage with like $500.
Hey, here's some trash.
I mean, there's a whole
story about how I put trash
in the background of The Guild.
Literally, if you
watch that show,
it's all trash in
the background.
MALE SPEAKER: That you
picked up, literally,
off the side of the street.
FELICIA DAY: Literally,
Or, I would, like,
get wrapping paper
and be, like, it's a
painting, Sharpies.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So you went
to college at 16, you said,
which was very awkward.
But you mentioned
math several times.
But you also majored in violin.
FELICIA DAY: Yes, I did.
Right?
MALE SPEAKER: And you've got
like, some deformed thumb,
right?
Or something?
Right?
FELICIA DAY: It doesn't
really straighten all the way.
It used to be way crooked.
And that's why my mom got me
into playing when I was two
because she saw, you
know, Oprah or something
and saw all these kids that
were two playing the violin.
And she was, like, well
clearly, that's fate.
[LAUGHTER]
It doesn't really add
up to me either, guys.
I don't know.
That's my mom though.
She basically was, like,
don't go to school one day
and I never did.
So that's how my mom was.
Who I'm very thankful for
because I basically grew up
kind of unfettered and
sort of followed everything
that I was interested
in and good at things
that I never would've
been good at normally.
But, at the same time, you
know, growing up in a bubble,
I'm socially awkward.
That's why I love video games.
Because if I'm at a party,
if there's not a person there
who can talk about video games
with myself, I'm leaving.
I'm going to play a video game.
So bye.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, OK.
So you were originally
accepted to Juilliard, right?
At 14.
FELICIA DAY: I got
into pre-program,
which is like a feeder school
for getting into Juilliard.
But we couldn't afford
to move to New York
and so-- my mom, on
a whim, was like,
let's go try out for things.
I mean, I love her a lot.
There's a story there
where she decided
to make me a Mouseketeer.
And we just drove to
Ohio without any reason
to [INAUDIBLE] and I was
like, where are we going, Mom?
And she was like, oh, there's
an audition for Mouseketeers.
You're going to
be a Mouseketeer.
And I'm, like, what
are you talking about?
I didn't know anything.
I don't know what
song-- she's like,
just sing what you were singing
in opera class last week.
So I was, like, singing
like a Schubert aria
to people in a Hilton.
And I did not pass
the first round, guys.
Surprisingly.
But you know--
MALE SPEAKER: Well, she put
you in a bunch of stuff,
though, because like, trying to
socialise you, I guess, right?
FELICIA DAY: She really tried.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
There was like dance class where
you were a famous astrologer?
FELICIA DAY: Yes.
She tried to make
me a Tejano star.
This is all in the book, guys.
Tejano is a kind
of Tex-Mex music
that I should never touch
in a very offensive way.
But she decided, hey, we'll
just name you Felicia Diaz.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I actually have never
said that aloud and I wrote it.
But I'm more
embarassed saying it.
[LAUGHTER]
But, you know,
those kinds of whims
she would follow in an
effort to just provide
any opportunity for my
talent, which she always
was supportive of.
So she's a wacky person that
I love very dearly because I
wouldn't be the person
I am without her,
sort of being a
little bit crazy.
MALE SPEAKER: You've
mentioned several times
she was like very into, just,
political activism, right?
FELICIA DAY: Oh, yeah.
I remember from the
youngest age folding
envelopes for, like, Gary Hart.
He was a guy, like 84.
I was, like,
probably five or six.
You know, I'm folding-- she's
like, here's how you do it
and I'm like stuffing envelopes
for all these loser candidates.
I mean, she would
support anyone who lost.
But Ross Perot is
the one where I
was like, 13 or 14 and we would
go on the road with everybody.
I would be out there picketing.
Yeah, you know, flat tax.
And I didn't know what
I was talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was definitely amusing
And it taught me, kind of,
being a rabble rouser was fun.
Really, we're just
on the corner, like,
trying to disrupt the world.
And I think that really fed
into what I do now, which
is like disrupting Hollywood.
It's very appealing to me.
And the fact that technology
gives us all the tools
to get our creation out there
in a way more direct way
is very appealing to me.
MALE SPEAKER: But you
have a brother, right?
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
Younger.
MALE SPEAKER: And
you and your brother
were originally in school at
a young, young age, right?
FELICIA DAY: I don't think
Ryan ever went to school.
He might have gone
to kindergarten,
but then my mom got into
a fight with a teacher
because he held his
scissors backwards.
And she was like,
I'm out of here.
So I went to first and
second gradee-- part
of second grade, first grade.
And then we just moved and
never went to school again.
I mean, literally.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: In
Mississippi though?
FELICIA DAY: In Mississippi.
They were not good schools.
And there was reason
not to put us in school.
But at the same time,
there was reason
to maybe get us tutors,
which she eventually did.
Because my dad was like,
what's up with the children?
[LAUGHTER]
So then I began to be
trained like a geisha.
She would put me in
every lesson possible.
I took, like, watercolor
with 90-year-olds
at the community college
when I was 12, you know.
I learned a little
bit of every language,
including Arabic,
because you never
know what will happen with
the world political situation.
I definitely cobble together
an interesting background.
And like I said, everything
that she raised me
in a weird way that made me
feel a little different when
I got into the world, but have
been things that I've channeled
into my career today.
MALE SPEAKER: Knowing
that there was like,
a social life, I guess,
or a, I guess, structure
to being in school,
like looking back on it,
do you think you're a little
bit, any different from what
your brother went
through, having not gone
to school at all?
FELICIA DAY: I don't think so.
I think we were both raised
in a pretty isolated world.
And our one conduit to the
world was, for me, theater,
being like the fifth orphan in
Olvier, over and over again.
Wherever I moved,
I was like, oh,
I loved pence, and
all that stuff,
like-- that was terrible.
Oklahoma-- I was, like,
chorus girl number seven
a couple times.
So that kind of family
was very appealing to me
because it gave
me a social world.
And then a dial up
computer-- we had a laptop.
I talk about it in the book.
Like it was this big.
The "laptop" is convenient
and it's literally a truck.
You have to have, like, a
forklift to move this laptop.
And my mom would
dial up to CompuServe
and just argue with people
over Reagan, mostly.
[LAUGHTER]
But I learned, that, hey, this
is how you connect to people.
And she wouldn't let me
dial up on CompuServe
because that was expensive.
It was like, I dont know, six--
MALE SPEAKER: It was hourly.
FELICIA DAY: It
was hourly, yeah.
It was like, $12 an
hour, or something.
I don't know.
Then we would play
King's Quest and we
would use the phone dial up.
This is how old, I
guess, I feel right now.
That you would have
to use the phone
to get a hint in
King's Quest to get
through a problem in the game.
You couldn't Google anything.
And we had like,
$500 phone bills
for trying to get
through King's Quest.
[LAUGHTER]
We got cut off from a lot of
things at a certain point.
But Prodigy came along,
this other online service.
MALE SPEAKER: I loved
Prodigy for Madlibs.
FELICIA DAY: Really?
You did that?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
I did Madlibs.
They were great.
FELICIA DAY: That's crazy
to me because so few people
were into that.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, I
loved the-- of course.
Look who I'm sitting on
stage with right now.
FELICIA DAY: Oh.
We might have been
Mailbox friends.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, gosh.
FELICIA DAY: It
was so primitive.
MALE SPEAKER: It
was 0.25 an email.
FELICIA DAY: Yes, but if you
created an extra account,
that you could write
an email to yourself,
and then leave it in
the inbox as a draft,
and somebody else would
log in and look at that.
That was how hard--
[LAUGHTER]
This is the equivalent of, like,
I'd walked 12 miles in snow.
MALE SPEAKER: Left
myself an email draft.
So throughout the early
chapters of the book,
or talking about
your early years,
you reference and show
images from your diary,
which I want to
read something here.
OK.
So in the diary--
[LAUGHTER]
You wrote, do you
know what I would
like to do more than anything,
except environmental and
biological stability
forever in the world?
I would like to travel in
time like in Quantum Leap.
It would be so wonderful.
Do you still have, A, this
diary, and B, these thoughts?
FELICIA DAY: Well,
I have the diary.
I don't think that anymore.
I mean, there's some
crazy things in the diary.
And I urge all of you to look at
yourselves because you probably
can make-- you can mock
yourself as a child.
It's very easy for all of us.
I think, at a certain
point, I wrote, like--
and there's startling
things in there.
You're just like, hey, today, I
learned what a miscarriage was.
It's where you spit
out a baby early.
By the way, today,
I got a beach bag.
And I'm reading this,
I'm like, horrified
that-- A, that's how I
would learn what that is.
And then B, that it was, just,
like, Anubhav and I got a beach
bag.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
I had this diary that I
talked to because no one
else would talk to me.
I talked to a little diary.
And it's kind of great to see.
That's was a very
formative period of my life
where I was very sequestered.
And after that, I sort of,
branched out a little bit more.
But having that to reflect
on, my weird, it's definitely,
it's proof that
I certainly would
have been a social outcast
probably in school either.
MALE SPEAKER: What about
your brother, Ryan?
What's he doing?
FELICIA DAY: He was
mostly, like-- he
liked to take things apart.
And he liked to be on
the computer and read.
He read a lot of Dungeons
and Dragons books.
Although my mother
wouldn't let us actually
play Dungeons and Dragons
with someone, anyone in person
because she thought-- she read
one article once about basement
satanic murders, and she
was, like, you can't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
So fast forward to
today, I actually
have a company that produces
Dungeons and Dragons.
Take that, Mom.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
that Ultima changed your life.
FELICIA DAY: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So for those who don't
know, what is Ultima?
FELICIA DAY: Ultima's like,
one of the first computer
role-playing games there is.
Richard Garriott created this.
And there were, you know,
I think eight of them.
And, I, literally,
thought this was
the world I wanted
to live in primarily
because you could
create an avatar that
looked kind of like yourself.
You could play a girl.
And you could steal bananas
from doors everywhere.
Like, every single door
was equipped with fruit
that you could
take for yourself.
And I loved the idea I could
steal things, you know,
in a virtual world.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
[LAUGHTER] Of course.
FELICIA DAY: It gave that
sense that I was free
and I could walk to the corner
without a molester, you know,
kidnapping me like my mom
told me that would happen.
I could walk to the corner
and kill a monster in the game
and nothing would happen
to me that was bad.
So I loved those games and
I connected with people
on Prodigy around that game.
And that was really,
kind of, the first,
really, close-knit social
group that I ever had.
And I tell a story
about meeting them.
And it's very awkward and funny.
MALE SPEAKER: I've got
a page of quotes here.
I want to read something
about Ultima here.
So, she says, the early
community, within Ultima,
taught me how wonderful
it is to connect
with like-minded people.
No matter how lonely
and isolated and starved
for attention you
are, there's always
a possibility in
the online world
that you can find a place
to be accepted or discover
a friendship that started
with the smallest of interest
but then could last a lifetime.
Your qualifications for
finding a place to belong
is enthusiasm and passion and I
think that's a beautiful thing.
So you had your first
kiss out of this.
FELICIA DAY: All right.
That's an awkward segue.
Because I felt, like, the
vibe in the room was like,
I'm inspired.
That's really what
tech is about.
No, let's talk about my awkward
kiss in the back of an Acura.
I mean, I met this guy on--
we had like a phone thing.
And, I mean, you've
got to read the book.
There's a picture that I
sent to boys on the internet,
like a physical picture.
And they all liked me very
much from this picture.
It was a terrible,
like, kind of,
glamour shots
picture with my butt.
I was wearing, like, a
fringe leather jacket.
It's so embarrassing, guys.
And anyway, all the
boys loved it online.
So we decided to meet
up in New Jersey, which
I'm going to New Jersey later.
And I still hate that state
because of this incident.
MALE SPEAKER: That
was my next question.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah,
New Jersey, sorry.
You're always going
to suck a little bit.
I mean, I'm not going to
tell them that to their face.
Please don't tweet it to them.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: This is airing
everywhere except New Jersey
so you're safe.
FELICIA DAY: Great.
Thank you.
Just geo-blocked.
Love you, Google.
So, basically, I met these
guys and I was kind of, like,
attracted to two of them.
And then one of them I
just eliminated because I
was like, nope, not there.
And then, the other
one, nope not there.
But my mom was like, you
have to kiss this guy.
So she made me kiss him
in the back of the car
while they went in to get
Bugles at the Walmart.
It's a whole story, guys.
Just read the book.
It's more mortifying to read
it than me talking about it.
Not really.
And that was my first
kiss and it was gross.
And it made me not
want to kiss anybody
because I was, like,
that was just sloppy.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
most people's first kisses
are probably like that.
FELICIA DAY: Really?
MALE SPEAKER: Mine was.
FELICIA DAY: What
was yours like?
Let's hear about--
MALE SPEAKER: You want
to talk about mine?
FELICIA DAY: Yes.
I'm going to put
you on the spot.
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, well real quick.
I'll talk about this.
It was in Dumb and Dumber.
FELICIA DAY: It
was in the movie?
MALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, in the movie.
FELICIA DAY: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Not filming
but we were there to watch.
[LAUGHTER]
We were there to watch the
movie and she came at me,
mouth open, full tongue.
And I was, like, and
it just went all over.
FELICIA DAY: Eew.
Why'd she go full tongue?
MALE SPEAKER: I don't know.
We were young.
FELICIA DAY: Ugh and with
the popcorn and everything?
You know, that's
like, [? asbestos. ?]
MALE SPEAKER: She didn't throw
popcorn at me in the thing, no.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah, but
just popcorn mouth.
You need to clean that out
with a wet nap before you kiss.
MALE SPEAKER: I will
tell younger self
to go back and fix that.
FELICIA DAY: I'm
sorry about that.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: It's all right.
Yeah, well, we share that.
That's great.
[LAUGHTER]
FELICIA DAY: Wet, sloppy firsts.
MALE SPEAKER: So young, awkward,
homeschooled, of course.
I'm into college, still awkward.
FELICIA DAY: Thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: It's all
in the book, people.
I didn't say it.
[LAUGHTER]
It's OK.
Did you have much of a social
life in college or were
you just so focused on
getting a 4.0, which
you are happy to say
you graduated with.
FELICIA DAY: I was valedictorian
in my class, I was.
I gave a speech on finding
the art in your science.
God, I hate myself,
in retrospect.
I did have a social life in
that the music building was
sort of this commune.
It's next to the
stadium, which gets
all the millions of dollars.
And then it's, like,
the music building.
Like, oh, those
people are musicians.
That supports the band
for the Texas football.
So being [INAUDIBLE]
musician there.
I loved it because everyone
treated me a little sister.
Because it was illegal,
of course, to date me.
So everyone was very sweet
to me and I was, like,
a little prodigy because
I was really flashy.
And I practiced 12
hours a day because I
had nothing else to do
because no one would date me.
So I became very good and I
joined the Austin symphony.
I mean, being a
part of that world,
because work was play then.
Because if you were
friends with somebody,
they'd hire you to
play at a wedding
or a depressing-- playing
Handel's "Messiah" for the five
millionth time for
Easter at some church.
That was a social
life, in a way,
but it certainly wasn't where
I got all those awesome college
memories that most people have.
I mean, I kind of wish I had
been exposed to crazy keggers,
you know?
No one every invited
me to anything,
just to be perfectly honest.
It's sad.
Not really.
I'm not that sad about it.
I mean, a little bit.
I really wish I had sex with
a lot more different people
just in retrospect.
[LAUGHTER]
Because then-- don't get
that look on your face.
You know that was
what college was for.
No?
MALE SPEAKER: There's
a time and a place
for everything and that
time and place was college.
FELICIA DAY: Exactly.
In college.
Exactly.
In a safe way.
Don't quote me on this.
MALE SPEAKER: Be safe.
Use protection.
FELICIA DAY: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, you don't
talk about the love life much,
so, you know.
FELICIA DAY: I try
to keep it clean.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Of course.
Everybody's laughing at that.
So after college, 4.0 GPA,
double-majored, awesome.
And then, all of a sudden,
you just go move to Hollywood.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Why?
FELICIA DAY: I knew
that someone would just
discover me on the sidewalk
and be, like, you're a star.
[LAUGHTER]
That's really,
actually, the truth.
I was very naive
in thinking that I
was going to move to Hollywood
and feel like I belonged, just
like that Oklahoma chorus girl.
We're just all going to
make a show together.
And that did not work out
the way I thought it was.
I did find a really great
career doing commercials
for, like, Cheetos, and
Anheuser-Busch, and the post
office.
And it was always, like,
hey, I'm a secretary.
And half my nose
would get on screen
and I would make, like,
$50,000 that year.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, national
commercials are no joke.
FELICIA DAY: They're no joke.
I made a great living,
but it's literally,
you're a soulless being.
They treat you like cattle.
You go in and there's
five of you in a row
and you go, like, hey,
would you like a washer?
Next.
Would you like a washer?
And you're, just,
literally, just ejected
for your literal outer being.
It was a great way
to pay the bills
but it was kind of
soul searing and that's
kind of what got me into my War
of Warcraft addiction, which
sort of enveloped my
life as a warlock.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll get
to that, but I want to--
FELICIA DAY: That was ominous.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
it's the next section.
FELICIA DAY: OK good.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I'm kind
of going chronologically
in the book, which is wonderful.
FELICIA DAY: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so your first
real gig was ultra low budget--
serial killers.
FELICIA DAY: Yes.
When you first move to LA,
you'd do anything, literally,
anything.
And there's a thing
called backstage
where you send your head shot
in anywhere who will take you.
And they're usually, like,
student films with 17-year-old,
you know, 18-year-old
kids who don't even
sound on your camera.
And you're expected to,
literally, beg for any job.
And I got my first start with a
movie called "Serial Killers,"
which was an audition
when the guy asked
me to show my breasts.
And I was, like, no, sir,
I will not show my breasts.
And I felt really good about it.
And then he hired me.
I was like, OK.
But I didn't show my breasts.
I was the best friend of the
girl who showed her breasts,
just for the record.
And I treated her with
pity the whole time.
MALE SPEAKER: But then
the check bounced.
FELICIA DAY: The
check bounced, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: The $90 check
bounced-- for five days.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah, and I
guess the moral of the story
is that I came to Hollywood
thinking that my straight A
attitude is going to get me far.
And it did not get me far
because that's-- Hollywood is
really more about appearances
and look more than anything.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Right So you were going through,
like, the commercial world
and the low budget world for,
like, six years, you said,
I think?
So why did you keep going
through all of this?
A lot of people can't
handle rejection.
FELICIA DAY: I mean,
I can't at all.
Like I've cried
more times in my car
than you can count
after feeling like,
hey, I did a terrible job.
Or, they judged me and
I messed that word up.
Yeah, it's really hard.
And I think growing
up homeschooled,
I didn't deal with
rejection at all because I
didn't get exposed to
it nearly enough, which
I think is an advantage
of being in school.
From what I hear,
high school is really
great for abusing yourself.
I mean, I'm not envious.
[LAUGHTER]
I watched "90210."
I know how those girls act.
So I think I would have been
a little over more resilient,
but I kept going
because I always
had this idea that
that next job was
going to get somewhere, right?
And that's sort of the carrot
that is danged in Hollywood.
That-- it's just
around the corner.
Just keep, you know,
keep going, keep going.
And sometimes that's true.
But for me, I just got
very upset with life
and just kept going
kind of feeling
sadder and sadder inside.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
that's a good segue,
I guess into your "World
of Warcraft" addiction.
[LAUGHTER]
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So this is
where Codex was created--
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Your
level 60 warlock.
FELICIA DAY: I always
call my characters Codex
after the Ultima-- it's
the book of infinite wisdom
because that was what every--
it's just really nerdy.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's an
entire chapter, 19 pages,
which is 7.3% of your book
about World of Warcraft.
Like that is, I think
it's the longest chapter.
FELICIA DAY: Did it feel long?
MALE SPEAKER: No, no it didn't.
I just got done reading
and I was, like, dang,
all the chapters are
like a whole timeline.
And then this is was like,
just World of Warcraft.
FELICIA DAY: I mean, if you
look at the hours spent,
it probably was proportional.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
how much do you play?
FELICIA DAY: I mean, I play,
like, 12 to 14 hours a day.
I would wake up
and be, like, well
I-- I would literally
have a to do list
for "World of Warcraft."
I would like, I need to fly to
this place to get dreamfoil.
I need to fly here and make
some [INAUDIBLE] titans.
I was the potion master.
I had a lot of responsibility
on my plate, OK?
MALE SPEAKER: How did
you get into it though?
FELICIA DAY: My
brother invited me.
And I've been addicted
to other online games,
"Diablo," "Puzzle Pirates," like
all these small, online games.
Because I really liked
connecting with people
and hanging out with
them and play games.
Like, I don't think games are
inherently addictive at all.
Like I don't want to paint
them in any negative term.
I feel like I needed
a Band-Aid on my life
and I used the "World of
Warcraft" as a Band-Aid
to fill the hours that I was
not happy being a rejected
actor over and over again.
I mean, because the thing
was, I made a living.
So I was just kind of hanging
out, waiting to be discovered.
MALE SPEAKER: Did your brother
get addicted as you did?
FELICIA DAY: No,
he quit before me.
He actually had some
self-preservation there.
I played very intensely
for eight months, at least,
hours and hours and
hours and hours a day.
So it got to the point where
I'd dream "World of Warcraft."
I'd wake up, I'd go
and play all day.
I'd go to bed with a plan
for the next day of gaming.
And I would dream in cartoon.
At a certain point, you
know I'm a smart person.
I'm like, maybe
this isn't healthy.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So you had
another Guild, right?
You found another Guild
online to play with?
FELICIA DAY: Yeah,
we had a raid.
So I created an alt, I
had a couple of alts,
because, you know, God knows
everybody needs another priest.
So I had to get that priest to
60 and that's another thing.
Then I can raid every
night and that's great
because everybody needs me.
And it's just sort
of a slippery slope
because there are always
people to play with.
There are always people who
felt like, I could provide help
to them.
And it was obviously a
false sense of purpose
but it was something
that I needed in my life.
And it was sort of
the quick fix for it.
MALE SPEAKER: How much
do you still play?
Do you play at all?
FELICIA DAY: I don't play WOW.
I definitely game a lot.
Like, I game around
20 hours a week.
I stream games a
couple times a week.
I mean, I produce a
lot of gaming content.
So I still love it a lot.
And I miss that sense of
camaraderie, I really do.
Because that sense of belonging
and working toward a goal
together is very fulfilling.
I try to find it in filmmaking
but it's really fun to take
down a monster, it really is.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: And
then during this time,
you were also trying to
write The Guild, right?
FELICIA DAY: Well, I quit WOW
cold turkey because I just
started skipping auditions
and at that point,
you know-- the lady
support group I was in
were like, OK so you're
being self-destructive.
And I quit and I decided
to write something.
They say write what you know,
something that you really
feel like you have something
to say about in this world.
And that was a bunch
of gamers who were
interacting online and offline.
It was definitely
something in my heart
I wanted to get on a
page, which was not
easy to get on the page.
I had to kind of force myself,
really put the screws in.
But I did finish a whole
draft and it was, literally,
the proudest thing
I've ever been--
because I made myself
finish something for myself
rather than external
ratification.
MALE SPEAKER: So the
ladies support group
you were talking
about, all stemmed out
of a love of pancakes.
You were meeting at
the Wafflehouse, right?
FELICIA DAY: Yeah, well
we ladies were just,
like, let's support each other.
And I think later it was
the secret that inspired it.
So let's not talk
about that part of it.
But it was a five,
four five ladies
that got together every
week and would be,
like, these are
my goals and this
is what I want to do this week.
And here's what I did this week.
And they would do all sorts of
productive things and I'd be,
like, I raided Zul'Gurub
and then we took down uh--
[LAUGHTER]
We took down [INAUDIBLE]
and I got a really great hat
this week.
And they would be,
like, I don't understand
anything you're doing.
So at a certain point, I
had enough self-reflection
and I was, like, OK,
I'm feeling guilty
that they're really
excelling in front of me.
MALE SPEAKER: So what
were they called?
FELICIA DAY: The Chicken.
It was called Chicken.
MALE SPEAKER: Chicken Ladies.
FELICIA DAY: I know.
It was so vaginal.
MALE SPEAKER: So vaginal?
Or magical?
FELICIA DAY: So vaginal.
It was magical too.
It's a magical vaginal.
MALE SPEAKER: So the comments
came in, series took off.
So on episode three was
when it was featured
on the homepage of YouTube.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
YouTube had this power back
then to actually feature
content that wasn't ads.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think they still do.
[LAUGHTER]
FELICIA DAY: I mean, there
was a curated front page,
The YouTube.
And literally, I wouldn't be
here without that one feature.
So I definitely
owe it to YouTube
for kind of skyrocketing
the Guild into visibility.
I think the woman's name
was Felicia Williams.
She actually curated the comedy
for the front page of YouTube
back then.
And a lot of the stars
were created from that
because that was the only
way you could get traffic
to be featured.
So that really was
the tipping point
where people found the show.
We wanted to make more and
we didn't have the money.
So we tried to figure it
out by putting a Paypal
button on those janky
Wordpress websites
that I just kind
of cobbled together
through video
tutorials on Lynda.com.
And I was like, it's beautiful.
It was terrible.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm so proud of it because
I made it from scratch.
It was fantastic.
I was, like, ey, I'll just
try this Paypal thing.
This was before Kickstarter too.
So I didn't expect
anyone to care.
And suddenly, we
had enough money
to shoot more of the episodes.
It was kind of the most
empowering thing I've ever
experienced to kind of go
around that gatekeeper who
was going to allow me
to tell a story or not.
And have the fans
support us directly.
It was really fantastic.
And it actually
invigorated me in a way
that I felt like I am
creating a community together
with other people.
I feel like I'm playing
again for the first time
in a long time.
And that's why I'm
still here doing
web content because
that sense of community
and feeling a sense of
belonging and making
people connect and
accept themselves
is really so much more
fulfilling than anything
external that I
can achieve before.
MALE SPEAKER: So you were
trying to shop around
to Hollywood execs
though and actually
get it picked up, right?
You had a lot of
execs that wanted
to take over control
if they wanted
to give any money at all.
Have you gone back
to anybody or met
with anybody that originally
was like, just horribly
mean and just rubbed
it in their face?
FELICIA DAY: Not rubbed it in
their face but, a lot of people
were, like, oh, it's so great
that you didn't sell to us.
I've actually had
people say that.
Because so many times I've
seen people option their book
or webseries, and it
gets into development
and-- the Hollywood
process is very lumberous
and there's a lot of external
reasons why things get made.
And honestly, if
anything ever gets made,
you should be, like,
man, victory to you.
You can retire because it
is so hard to turn this vote
and get anything on camera.
So I've been told in
the past to people
that I just turned down that
they were like, yeah, you
were right.
You did it better than
we could have done,
even by taking away the
rights to your show and kind
of controlling everything.
That's what I really
wanted to protect.
Because I didn't want to give
up the thing that I loved
so much just to
make that business
move to look fancier
for Hollywood.
Because I didn't care as much
about pleasing them anymore.
I really just want
to please our fans.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
There's another quote I want
to read here, specifically,
about the support group.
You said, "Find
a support group--
find a group to support
you, to encourage you,
to guilt you into doing.
If you can't find one,
start one yourself.
Random people enjoy
having pancakes.
Make a goal.
Then strike down things
that are distracting you
from that goal, especially video
games, unless it's this book.
Finish reading and then start.
Put the fear of
God into yourself.
OK, I'm not religious.
Whatever spiritual
ideas float your boat.
Read some obituaries.
Watch the first 15 minutes
of Up, I don't care.
Just scare yourself good.
[LAUGHTER]
FELICIA DAY: You have a finite
number of toothpaste tubes
you'll ever consume
while on this planet.
Make the most of that clean
tooth time for yourself."
MALE SPEAKER: Well said.
Thank you.
FELICIA DAY: I mean, if you
think about it, next time you
use toothpaste, it's like,
literally, it's a count down.
It's really depressing.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: That
was a long quote too.
Sorry.
So I want to take it
down a little bit.
So you mentioned a little of,
like, depression and anxiety.
It's sort of an underlying
theme throughout a lot
of your adult life after
college and what not.
And maybe even during
it a little bit.
Why talk about that in the book?
Why'd you bring that up?
FELICIA DAY: I mean, I
think that reflecting
on a lot of the things
I've done my life,
are or done in my life, I feel
like there have been things
in my brain ruling
me, in a way that
almost is as much peer
pressure as people
to abandon things when
you're in puberty.
My anxiety and problems in
my brain made me steer away
from things that probably
would have been fulfilling
had I not let them rule me.
And the fact that I went
through such a tough time.
After Geek and Sundry
started, ending
the Guild-- the crushing-- you
know, just a startup company--
I wasn't prepared.
I didn't have the tools.
We didn't scale-- we
weren't scaled big enough
to really handle the amount
of work that we had to do.
And I wanted to execute.
I had a reputation to maintain.
I had a bar to set
that was really high.
I was the Guild, you know?
So when all that came
crashing down on my shoulders,
I just couldn't handle
the stress of it.
MALE SPEAKER: You
got physically ill.
FELICIA DAY: I got
physically ill.
I have a lot of health
problems because of the stress.
Because stress can
kill you, guys.
I had a nervous
breakdown, really.
I shattered into
a lot of pieces.
And putting back
those pieces made
me kind of look at my life
in a different way and think,
hey, I don't want anyone
to go through this
and feel as alone as I
have through this process.
Because the minute I started
reaching out to people
and getting their advice and
help and therapists and doctors
and things like that,
like, I started to heal.
But in the moment, I didn't
realize I had an alternative.
I didn't know I had tools
to like pull myself up
from the mud pit.
I was like, I'm down here.
I guess I'll just go under.
I mean, I really
had no awareness.
And I think the more
people talk about
that, especially if
somebody likes my work
and they see the
external things,
like, hey, that's
what success is.
Or, she has it all, or
I want to be like her.
I do it with other actors.
Ah, it must be easy
being Lady Gaga.
I mean, I'm sure she
wakes up and is just
depressed a lot because
of all the pressure.
And everyone's got
their problems.
And success, quite frankly,
can bring as many stresses
and pressures as failure.
And nobody told me that ever.
I always thought that I
was just a broken person,
not being able to handle
all this opportunity I got.
And when I started
building myself back up
and being able to
cope a lot better,
I wanted to write about it
in a very transparent way
so that everyone could relate.
And if they had any
opportunity to be
more aware of the
patterns in their own life
and get help through
my story, that
would be worth writing
the whole book for.
MALE SPEAKER: There
are microphones
in the aisles over here
if anybody has questions.
Please step up and ask.
And I'm going to actually
read another quote, which
I think is very timely for
what we just talked about.
So about the depression,
you said, "In the end,
I'm able to look back without
shame or regretful nostalgia,
and I think, 'you've made
something great.' And something
new will come around or not.
Either way, do the work you
love, and love yourself.
That's all you could do in this
world in order to be happy."
So I hope that-- yes,
anybody reading this book
will find some
inspiration from it.
Because, I think, being
as open and as transparent
as you were about
that is probably
enough to get a lot of people,
like, just a little bit--
I don't know how to phrase
this-- it's personal for me
too-- that it'll allow
people to just, maybe,
take a little bit initiative
to ask for help that maybe they
wouldn't have otherwise.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
You know, I mean, I think we're
greater than just ourselves.
And a lot of times, especially
growing up the way I did,
I feel alone.
And I feel like I need to
be on an island to myself.
And being vulnerable
to other people
and having that kindness repaid.
And drawing the strings
between yourself
and other people is an amazing
tool, not only to create.
Like, I would never
have created The Guild
without that Chicken group.
And I never would have
stayed in this business
without the community around it.
And it's really that sort of,
like, safety net of connection
between all of us that
really catches us when we're
most vulnerable and we need it.
And bounces us up when
we're buoyant or joyous
and we want to share
something with the world.
MALE SPEAKER: Question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like a
lot of your work, especially
The Guild, is about the way that
games can create communities
from people from all
sorts of different places.
And so I'm wondering, like,
with the ethics movement that
will not be named, we see
this, like-- it seems recently
there's this, what seems to me,
like, a theme of like, identity
being very important
in a negative way.
And I'm wondering if you think
that that aspect of gaming
that was really
appealing to you,
do you think that's changing?
Where do you think that
that pushback comes from?
FELICIA DAY: I mean, I
think that-- I actually have
a chapter of that in the book.
And I was actually wary of,
like, do I put this in here?
It actually happened
after my draft was done.
The chapter was about negative
comments and various attacks
I've had on me over the years,
especially for the label "gamer
girl."
So that chapter was in
there and that incident
that I experienced last fall was
just almost like an addendum,
the peak of that sort
of underlying movement
that had-- you're right.
It's kind of like a basic
resentment or intractability
about identity of gamer.
And because gaming has become
so much more than it used to be,
and expanded to represent a
lot more voices, and a lot more
differing viewpoints, I
think it got to the point
where it became too big
for the umbrella that
existed to include everybody.
And then people are like,
well, I don't feel represented.
I don't feel like I fit in here.
I love this, but I would love to
feel more comfortable this way.
And some people just can't bend.
They feel personally
threatened by that.
And I think it's a
tragedy that gaming even
has a black eye because
of these people.
And to this day,
I daily see people
say that I'm afraid of
gamers and I alienate gamers.
And it personally betrays
me because my identity
is so close to gaming myself.
What I think is good that
comes out of it is that for me,
personally, the
community I have,
we try to be as
proactively positive
as that small minority of
people are proactively negative.
And that gaming leaders
come out and say,
this is not acceptable.
This is not what gaming is.
That's not the gaming I know.
And I think the more--
everyone steps forward
and represents differing
points of view in saying,
you know what?
You can't do that.
That's not acceptable.
That really fosters
an environment.
I think, even technologically--
it's incumbent upon platforms
to give people the tools to
regulate their environment.
Like, to me, YouTube
needs to do better
to be able to give the tools,
not only to the creators,
but to the community, to
regulate the environments
that they're
hanging out around--
and the community to create.
I started a Twitch channel.
And that environment gives
the moderators so much leeway
and we have so many
proactive people
who create a place, where
I would walk into that chat
room in a virtual
or physical way,
and want to meet everybody
in that chat room.
And everybody can be
included if they want
to be friendly and inclusive.
I wish YouTube had
those tools-- to be
able to create a YouTube
comment and a YouTube place,
a sense of place
under those videos,
that people could feel
free to go in and enjoy
the company of everybody there.
So I think that incredibly
negative incident
is positive in that
gaming is a lot stronger
in a unified front against
those kind of things.
And hopefully, platforms
and leaders stand up
and say, let's just focus on
the love of games, which I
think we all have in our heart.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FELICIA DAY: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So as you mentioned,
on the internet, like,
no matter how small or how
strange something might be,
like, you will
always find someone
that you can bond with over it.
What is the most
obscure thing that you,
or someone that you know, have
bonded over with someone else?
And then a friendship just
bloomed and blossomed?
FELICIA DAY: I
mean, I have a love
of Anne of Green Gables,
which is, like, immense.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, I couldn't have
been more obsessed.
I met Megan Follows and started
crying at a certain point--
because she played
Anne of Gables
in the Disney
Channel mini-series.
You guys are just blink
as hell over here.
And when I say that, a lot of,
especially women, are like,
oh my god, Anne of Gables is
my hero, especially redheads.
So it's like she's
the redhead heroine
that the redhead
girls always are,
like, she's literally
my Barbie, or whatever.
So I think that is
something that-- and I
think-- the way
that I-- I'm talking
about Anne of Green Gables
and I'm lighting up with joy.
And that's really what we
should be able to follow.
Whatever it is that lights up
your joy in talking about it,
and you meet somebody at
a party and you're like,
thank God this guy
knows about, you know,
cool collector
sneakers, or like,
"DOTA," or something like that.
That instantly
creates a connection.
That's what I love about
geek culture and the way
the internet is constructed.
There's nothing more
tragic than somebody
abandoning something they love
and lights them up with joy
just because the
people around you
are saying that you're
weird or you should hide it.
Like that's almost
a form of bullying,
in a sense--
unconscious bullying,
but asking you to
conform is a sense
of rounding out your
corners and dissuading you
from letting your joy out.
Like, that's really all we
have in life to-- there's
a lot of downs.
We have to pay bills, you know?
Life is inherently kind
of crappy sometimes.
And the more joy we
could spread and connect
with other people, the batter.
And that's what I think
the ultimate Polyanna
view of the internet is.
Does that answer it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Anne of Green Gables.
Thank you.
FELICIA DAY: Wait, what's
your weirdest thing?
[LAUGHTER]
Furries?
AUDIENCE: My weirdest?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
A lot of the big
stuff like Doctor Who.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
FELICIA DAY: Yeah.
Doctor Who's a good one.
AUDIENCE: Love, love Doctor Who.
MALE SPEAKER: You freaked
out over Matt Smith, right?
FELICIA DAY: Oh, I did.
Matt Smith's in here.
I've seen him at parties--
anyway, there's a story.
It's really pathetic.
[LAUGHTER] You'll read about it.
Well, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I can't think of any.
All right, I'm sorry.
I'm putting you on the spot.
I'm horrible.
OK bye.
MALE SPEAKER: When
was your first kiss?
No?
OK.
FELICIA DAY: Where
was your first kiss?
We want details.
Was it juicy?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: When I
think of, kind of,
five-minute video content,
episodic episodes,
like The Guild, the Legend of
Neil, I kind of think of you.
But I haven't really seen it
become popularized in any way.
And I wonder if you had any
ideas why it's not happening?
FELICIA DAY: Yeah, it's
really interesting.
And I think early
in Geek and Sundry,
I tried to maintain
that kind of content.
And unfortunately, if you know
things about film production
is that anything scripted
is extremely difficult.
If you walk on the
set of The Guild,
most fans were, like,
oh my god, I thought
it was just you and a camera.
You can't-- you
know, "Supernatural,"
a show that I was
on for four seasons,
that's-- 300 people
work on that show.
So the scale of making scripted
content, especially at volume,
is exorbitantly expensive
and advertising dollars just
haven't been able to
be there to prove it.
So, say, you have an investment
into, like, Geek and Sundry,
and you have minutes that
you need to make of content.
What is a better investment
in a practical way?
$100 a minute or
$1,000 a minute,
if you don't have the
advertisers out there
to really support this
brand new kind of content?
Well, you have to make
cheaper content, right?
And then you have these
bloggers who are amazing
and they have one camera and
they're making $2 million
a year in product placement
and they, literally, do
have a camera and themselves.
And what is a better
economic landscape?
Well, The Guild is a
great economic landscape
in that it's an IP
that can be exploited
on different properties.
I can make a movie one day.
I license it to video
games and board games
and t-shirts and
things like that.
That has a long life.
So that IP-- look at
"Star Wars," you know?
That's the biggest.
But it's a much more
risky investment
because you don't know if you're
going to make your money back.
Better to just make lots
of low-budget content.
And I think after The
Guild and Legend of Neil,
there was kind of the
potential of, like, hey,
short-form scripted
is going to be it.
And a lot of things tanked.
So then you went the safe
route and you invested
in low-budget content,
which is now more popular.
And those stars that are being
created now on those platforms
are now funding long-form
scripted content.
So it's kind of
this weird cycle.
And I'm excited by the fact that
long-form scripted-- especially
YouTube is investing
in it, which
is amazing-- and all
sorts of other platforms,
like Vessel and-- everyone's
making scripted content now.
So it seems like the
pendulum went one way.
And now it's coming back.
But the short form
is just harder
to license in different
iterations across platforms.
It's a bunch of wonky
business stuff that,
basically, is like, make a movie
or make really cheap content.
That's kind of where
web video is right now.
But who knows in five years.
You never know.
That's the cool thing
about this space.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: I actually have just
a really light-hearted question.
FELICIA DAY: Oh, good.
Because that was boring,
what I just said.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I'm a mom of an
eight-year-old girl and we
both game together.
And we have theme songs
for ourselves when we win.
And my daughter asked me to ask
you what is your winning dance
or theme song?
Oh my gosh.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: You know
you have to get up, right?
FELICIA DAY: I mean,
my-- please don't.
[LAUGHTER]
You can dance for me.
It's probably Eye of the Tiger.
Or, take, these broken wings,
and learn to fly again.
It's like my karaoke song.
I just have to rub really bad
'80s songs in people's faces.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
That's probably an answer.
That's a terrible song.
But that's the cutest
story I've ever heard.
Thank you for that.
MALE SPEAKER: So you've
got the wonderful book out.
You've got Geek and Sundry.
What's next for you?
FELICIA DAY: I'm working on
a lot of different projects.
I'm trying to get back
to more scripted content.
The business has really
taken a lot of my time.
The book took up last year.
And now I'm working
on a TV pilot,
whether it's digital
or TV, that's cool.
I'm working on
something to direct.
And hopefully, making another
long-form piece of content
that's scripted.
That's really what I love.
And just keeping
all the platforms
juggling on Geek and Sundry,
YouTube, and everything
that we do.
So, I mean, I love
having 15 hats.
And although it tends
to break my neck because
of the heaviness,
I just can't stop.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
you did mention
that you do keep all the gifts
that people ever give you.
So we got this wonderful
Talks at Google Android.
FELICIA DAY: What?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
FELICIA DAY: Did you
get this free somewhere?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just kidding.
Is it a regift?
It's OK.
I want it.
MALE SPEAKER: No, we
give them to our guests.
FELICIA DAY: It's really sweet.
Thank you.
It's adorable.
MALE SPEAKER: You're welcome.
FELICIA DAY: I'm sorry.
That was really tacky.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Is it free?
[LAUGHTER]
So, yeah, You're Never Weird
on the Internet (Almost):
A Memoir, available-- it
comes out today, right?
FELICIA DAY: It's
out today, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: It is out today.
It's there in the back.
Are there still any copies?
I don't know.
On Amazon and of
course, Google Play.
Get your copy.
Pick up one if you haven't.
So thank you for coming out.
Everyone, please, help me.
[APPLAUSE]
FELICIA DAY: Thank
you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Wonderful.
FELICIA DAY: Thank you.